chancen auftun sind solche momente die
doreen den steht an ihrem job liegt
die hatte sich bei denen der
vertrauensstelle der thüringer polizei
beschwert weil sie kein praktikum bei
der hundestaffel bekam doreen hat ein
treffen mit den kollegen arrangiert
ist es auch schön wenn man wirklich
einfach mal wünsche erfüllen kann und
sowas ist natürlich total toll man kann
nebenbei noch den hund kuscheln und
hatte eine junge frau die hoch motiviert
jetzt sagt ich will hundeführer würden
werden sie ist eine sehr höfliche eine
sehr engagierte person und nicht
wirklich froh dass ich kennengelernt
habe dinge durchsetzen auch gegen
widerstände drehen den städt war mal in
der rugby-bundesliga und war auch mal
punk heute ist sie eine der wenigen
schwarzen beamtinnen der polizei
und betreut unter anderem auch die
rassismus seminare in der polizeischule
ihr job dabei die kollegen
sensibilisieren seit rassismus den
erlebt man jeden tag das ist halt so man
gewöhnt sich daran und man hinterfragt
das irgendwann nicht mehr weil man würde
ja mobil fertig werden
schlecht ist es wenn das dann halt
polizeiliches handeln bestimmt und wenn
ich den leuten nicht mehr trauen kann
die das gewaltmonopol ausüben dann habe
ich aus meiner sicht ein riesenproblem
dann geht nämlich unsere demokratie
flöten dass sie aus zweifacher
perspektive auf solche probleme sieht
ein gewinn für die polizei sagen die
kollegen
doreen wächst in den 80ern in der ddr
auf ihr vater aus tansania die mutter
aus thüringen die tochter merkt schnell
sie ist anders man ist ja von klein auf
quasi steht man da um den fokus und ist
bestimmten umgang von menschen gewöhnt
ist blicke gewöhnt ist hinter dem rücken
tuscheln gewöhnt man kann es zwar noch
nicht in worte fassen dann kann es auch
noch nicht richtig einordnen aber man
merkt die leute behandeln ein anderes
als die anderen kinder in der
vertrauensstelle hat sie oft beschwerden
auf dem tisch jung schwarz männlich
immer wieder in polizeikontrollen auch
sie selbst macht ähnliche erfahrungen
immer noch so in der stadt erfurt im
bürgeramt da würde ich noch bei
aufenthaltstitel gefragt das hat mich
natürlich sofort wütend gemacht die dame
hat es nicht geschafft sich zu
entschuldigen sondern die hat sich dann
auch darauf hochpushen hat dann auch
dagegen gehalten also ein einfaches
entschuldigung hätte daher schon
gereicht das hat sie nicht hingekriegt
ich habe mich aber auch im nachgang
tatsächlich nicht beschwert nehme diese
geschichte aber sehr gerne um das leuten
klar zu machen dass
dieses ständige behandeln dieses
ständige rassistische behandeln von
personen dazu führen kann dass ich dann
eben bei der polizeikontrolle eben nicht
mehr freundlich bin dinge von beiden
seiten sehen ein thema das sich durch
ihr leben zieht neben der polizeiarbeit
hat sie erst kommunikation studiert
macht jetzt einen master in jugend und
medien und gibt kurse in schulen
unter anderem zur diskriminierung und
rassismus ein thema das kinder bewegt
weil tatsächlich feststellung so dass
auch im sechsten klasse die kinder schon
durchaus wissen was rassismus ist das in
ordnung die wissen auch was
antisemitismus ist oder diskriminierung
sie können vielleicht nicht unbedingt so
mit den fachbegriffen immer unterlegen
das genau wissen deswegen aber sie
wissen man darf menschen nicht ungleich
behandeln das ist durchaus bewusst
freut sich dass doch viele junge leute
so auf das thema schauen denn es gibt
auch andere eindrücke aus thüringen von
menschen die abstempeln und ausgrenzen
anderes label und daneben es auch zu
gewalttätigen übergriffen kommt mit
begründung du gehörst du nicht
das ärgert mich nicht nur sondern dass
das macht auch irgendwo angst
ich kann mittlerweile von mehreren
leuten wenn wir dazu unsere geschichte
gehört dass die sich überlegen wo sie
hinziehen also die wollen wir nicht mehr
wohnen auch deshalb engagiert sie sich
bei den grünen ist kreisvorstand in
erfurt waren februar delegierte bei der
wahl des bundespräsidenten
bild
privat politikerin beruflich beamten das
ist erlaubt aber eben doch auch eine
gratwanderung der anlass für sie waren
polizeikollegen die für die afg in den
landtag einzogen nachdem sich quasi
jetzt einige beamtinnen und beamte dann
also auch offen zu bestimmten parteien
bekannt haben habe ich mir dann gedacht
dann kann ich aber auch zu den grünen
gehen die feste und demokratischen lager
unterwegs sind und mich da engagieren
nicht alle finden das gut es gibt
unschöne kommentare auf social media
dann geht sie raus mit ihren hunden
abschalten den kopf und das telefon das
blocken das habe ich gar nicht gezählt
passiert schon relativ häufig zum
schluss geht es um meine gesundheit und
meine psychohygiene und dann ist so ein
blog einfach schneller als wenn man da
anfängt so diskutieren was die leute am
ende so nicht wollen
ständig bestätigung braucht sie ohnehin
nicht dass doreen den steht immer wieder
unterschätzt wird nimmt sie gelassen 50
ähnlich formuliert das sind die leute
die sind von haus aus kompetent oder
komme ich natürlich dann um die ecke bin
eben nicht mehr ich bin eben nicht 50
und dann werden wir bestimmte
kompetenzen einfach nicht nicht wer
nicht gesehen also ich hab jetzt
mittlerweile arbeite ich am dritten
hochschulabschluss
das wundert tatsächlich die leute immer
noch auch deshalb hat sie sich so für
erb- und deren traum von der
hundeführerin eingesetzt über
erwartungen anderer hinauswachsen doreen
den stadt weiß was das heißt